the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
this is a gold medal match of the
protest league
st louis archbishops versus armenian
eagles
oh special story oh super gm's
fabiano dominguez wesley so
jeffrey strong eagles playing all
sub 2700s
can i compete in any way
shape and form for the world
championship or will they be left with
nothing
but [ __ ] and dreams find out
now
the st louis archbishops the definitive
pro-chess league dynasty
with world championships in 2017 and
last year
and a bronze medal in 2018 the
archbishops
led by fabiano carawana are going for
their third
championship in four years but it won't
be easy
with the armenia eagles led by parham
magsoodlu
looking to avenge their semi-final round
loss
to the archbishops last year it's time
the championship the saint louis
archbishops
versus the armenia eagles
thank you for the kind and measured
words for
from mike comer and welcome to the
championship day we're seeing those
archbishops are going to face off
with the armenian eagles it's actually
an easy round for both teams but let's
go and order
let's take a look at the saint louis
archbishop's
road to the championships so
the archbishops actually had an 8-0
undefeated record which the
continued to the playoffs with beating
the pandas with an outstanding
score of nine and a half
actually bigger than that much much
bigger
in the tents they beat
the pandas and they're facing off
armenia
who beat the chess bras and ironically
enough
the chesrras did not just lose to the
eagles but they also succumbed
to the pandas that the archbishops just
defeated
so the bronze medal actually has gone to
the pandas
and now we're going to see a final
between these two undefeated teams
all on eight zero from the
first season but
let's take a look at what the armenian
eagles
scored and how did they get here
so interestingly enough both teams
go on for the title hunt with an
undefeated score
both eight zero and as
we already talked about has defeated the
chess bras
and that's got them to the finals
also an interesting tidbit that zaven
andre asian
their main man is not present in this
match is not playing
even though he's been one of the most
important players for the armenian
eagles he's not playing and in fact he
even participated in saint louis chess
club events
as well however it is a very young team
with talents such as sadvani and maxodlu
and that they ground petrossian not the
older
not the iron one but still a tigran
petrossian
so a very dangerous team but all that
said it is still the archbishops that
are
considered big favorites and let's take
a look
at our team the dream team
as we would call it we have vastly so
fabiano carana lenny dominguez
and jeffrey zhang but in pre-season
we had le quang liam benjamin bach
var akobian and alejandro ramirez
in the matches and how could we forget
about the biggest manager of all time
mr mike comer in
any case this is going to be a very
interesting match
possibly as i had a little bit of talk
with the manager himself he said
that there's only one way armenia can
fight and if they
fight early on so let's see the roster
that we have at the centers versus
armenia match
so the archbishops have fabiano caruana
lenny dominguez
wesley so and jeffrey zhang facing off
against parham maxwell blue height
martyrossian
so interestingly enough archbishops are
better in all possible match-ups
the big question is how can the eagles
try to
match against that and for them to
actually
put up a good chance they will have to
fight on
from round one and hope that
they'll survive till round three
if so then
we'll see but in any case corona
is going to face max so
how does the pairing goes so they
will face each player so it's going to
be around robin
until the end where one plays board one
can we have that
one back again for a second the previous
one
so it is going to be
board one facing board number one board
two versus two
yes thank you fabiano corona is going to
face
maxo lenier versus hayek martirossian
wesley so versus tigran petrossian and
jeffrey zhang
versus radnak sadhuwani but as we talked
about that already
this is a big advantage for the st louis
team
so if they manage to prolong it and
still have a bit of a lead this is to
their advantage
as on all boards st louis has
a higher rating so
without that out and if it's still a tie
we will have a look at the match format
so the match format is
a four versus for all play all format
so everyone will face everybody and as i
said
they're going to face off one versus one
two versus two
in the final round match win gives
a team ten points in the standing eighth
and a half points clinches
so any team that reaches eight and a
half in this
match will be crowned as protest league
champion at the big chess party
every game point gives the team one
point in the standings the time control
is ten minutes
plus a 2 second increment so let's take
a look
in case of a tie what happens
in case of a tie there will be a playoff
so nobody has an upper hand in that case
so they are going to head off to a
tiebreaker where they're going to have a
ladder format
where board 4 will face board 4
and if our board 4 let's say
jeffrey zhang keeps on winning then he
can
actually go on and defeat the whole team
and that would be the end of it all but
if board
4 and board 4 so if board 4
wins against board 4 then plays 3 and
loses
then they'll continue from then on
until they reach the top and they will
play until
there is a decisive result therefore
the latter format and
here is the excerpt
that if the match between two teams
first board is drawn they continue
to play until the with colors reversed
but if they have a decisive game that'll
be the
decider
so with that out of the way we're sort
of
waiting for the games to start
by the way i can show you what is going
to happen in round one
so round one raunak sadvani and
te te gran petrosian are going to be
white
versus fabiano caruana and leni
dominguez
so as predicted the armenians will have
to try in round one
just to keep pace as
they are going to be headed towards the
later rounds that is against them so
wesley so and jeffrey zhang
is going to be white versus hayek marti
rossian
wesley is playing white and jeffrey
zhang is facing off blue so let's take
a look at jeffrey's game versus maxwell
which is again a very critical game
so here is the game
let me get there so jeffrey zhang
decides to play a solid catalan
where maxwell is also being fairly solid
knight h5 knight f6 and in fact this is
an open invitation by max zulu that the
draw
is great that kind of means
that the armenian team is being very
tactical here
they just want to hold on the
blackboards and
hope for owen on the white ones
b3 jeffrey calmly says i want to have
a game of chess thank you a5 and this
is if correct was played
in a giri topalov match where bishop c3
knight d2 e4 happened with a solid
but a slightly better position and in
fact jeffrey
does play bishop c3 with the
aforementioned plan of knight d2
e4 trying to break it open
so far all theory with
a rather balanced position but with lots
and lots of pieces on the board
anything can really happen so i would
expect knight d2
as bishop a6 kind of threatened this
idea of a dtx
c4 b5
rare idea if in case of c5 b4 and the e2
pawn would be hanging
so i would assume that jeffrey is going
to give up a pawn with e4
and after takes takes takes he does
shatter and lose a pawn but at the end
of the day it's a doubled pawn and it's
more of a target
than really an asset so the game will
still go on and it is
still likely be slow theory but
e4 will definitely give compensation for
jeffrey but let's take a look around
and let's take a quick peek at wesley's
game
versus hayek martirossia
so it started off as a berlin not of a
big surprise
should be six castle knight d7
bishop e7 d4 so this is a typical
structure
where white is hoping to create a
kingside majority
and then head towards an end game f6
knight a5 just trying to clamp down
black's position
put pressure on the b and c pawns
and now wesley goes on to
exchange take sticks bishop e7
and now they're looking at this position
now one of the moves that i would
consider is definitely bishop e3 trying
to
put a bit of pressure on a7 now you
might be asking me
why does hayek marty rossian play this
line
if he has a disadvantage on the king
side
well to tell you the truth there's a
bishop pair compensating
for the lack of an extra pawn here on
the f
file and that makes this position
relatively even not that wesley cannot
go and try to press for a win but marti
rossian
does have ample counter chances king f7
which is a little bit
fishy to my taste as there's still some
rooks on the board
and eventually f4 f5 can be annoying
if you capture bishop takes f4 and i
will have a target on c7
plus your king is a little bit out in
the open
so if anything it still feels like
wesley so is the one pressing not by a
whole bunch slightly better but
is definitely still the one pressing but
let's take a look
how fabiano does against
his opponent sadvani so let's
rotate the board and i think we're
seeing
a good old taiman of paulson
bishop g2 the classic bishop g2 line
bishop c5 that's actually a sign
that fabi is getting ready for some
aggressive play
knight takes c6 dc bishop g5
h5 and whenever you see h5 moves
in the tadaimanov that means that black
is going
all in so that means fabiano is trying
to
clinch it and actually he did
get sadvani off guard as he has six
minutes versus
eight so what is fabiano planning to do
clearly if you say h5 you want to say
h4 next and even then
you could sacrifice your rook takes and
have
very good play on the dark squares so i
sort of expect
sadvani to react in some way
shape or form
e5 could be interesting trying to give
up the pawn
but have lively play for it
queen f3 he does not play so
he goes queen f3 but
i'm not sure if this threat is that big
so one of the ideas that i could see
working is bishop d4
just trying to consolidate but that
could potentially run into knight e2 and
some complications
for sure fabiano shouldn't allow bishop
takes f6
because not only would that shatter his
pawn structure
but it would also cost a pawn
there bishop takes takes queen takes
so potentially knight h7 could make some
sense
however after some exchanges i think
white would be slightly better not by a
whole lot
but still would have a bit of an
advantage
the more i look at it the more i like
this with white
even though it did look promising with
the time edge that fabi had
but let's take a look on board 4
on ward 3 that is between petrossian
and leni dominguez
so we had a classic good old classic
king's indian attack beloved by bobby
fischer himself
but this time lenier is actually playing
on the black side b5 knight f1
the attack is actually famous
for opposite side attacks with white
trying to checkmate
and black trying to take over on the
queen side
should be seven rook c8 a typical but a
very nice maneuver
by lenie it actually gives the option
for black
to cover the h7 and f7 squares
with a later knight f8 or bishop f8
bishop g5 bishop takes g5 takes
knight d4 again another idea to clear it
up
take 6 rook c1 queen a5
a3 rook c7 and even though
this pawn is a little bit weak there's a
target on c2 that lenny is trying to
use for his benefit at b3 trying to
attack the d4 pawn and win a tempo with
attacking the queen
in b6 queen d2 knight b8
f4 and players are thinking and as i can
see
lenny is in some time trouble has four
minutes versus
8 20. that really doesn't bode too well
although he could definitely go for a5
a4 and b4
brakes pressing on the c2 square
so if t gran petrossian isn't in time to
go
for g4 f5 then a5 a4 b4 might come
fast and then this counter play
might prove to be decisive on the other
side
i would kind of expect a very
double-edged struggle in this match
because if white's attack starts
brewing it is either a win or a loss
there's no end between in this case
the king is just in too much danger so
if g4 f5 f6 happens
it's either mate or black gets through
on the queen side
faster f5 so f5 is
actually a typical move saying i don't
have time
for wasting a tempo with g4 so i'm going
to go ahead and play f5
immediately f takes
f takes bishop ht that's a very smart
move by
petrossian pressuring on e6
and you can see that white will be going
and lining up on the f5 as quickly as
possible
before lenie could do his thing
on the queen side rook e8 but this
actually looks
kind of dodgy rook f1 knight
takes e5 rook e1 pressing there
sounds like an idea to give up the pawn
for some play
but it's a question if it's actually
good enough petrossian avoids it plays
queen e2
diff over defends that and plans to
double up
on the f file
now black has no choice but
to start roaming and trying to attack on
that side
or maybe try to get this knight to g6
but the more passive black gets the more
likely
this will end in trouble
let's take a look what's happening in
the
jeffree game against maxo lou
look f1
salad has changed since
so instead of e4 jeffrey decided to play
knight e5
i take c5 d e knight d7 take sticks
bishop d4 and we get this semi
catalan slash french structure this
bishop is a little bit
out of sorts and e4 being an extra
option that you don't get
in the french b4 e4
and jeffrey does it c8
queen b2 and you can actually see the
difference between the two positions
white has fairly good pieces and
good activity while most of the black
pieces
are on the first and eighth and seventh
rank
still let's see 5 ed ed
knight f1 and now there is a clear
target
for jeffrey to latch onto knight e4
rook c1 take stakes rookie 3 again
eyeing this pawn
rook takes bishop takes queen c2
and here comes the big question
if there is a winning shot after bishop
b7
now if black would just pass then
there would be a road awakening after
knight takes d5
as after queen takes intake c8 would win
the bishop and probably
another piece on e4
however i kind of expect something like
bishop b7
where i think white's position is better
but is
not quite yet winning
actually they agreed to draw which is
an okay result however i think maxulou
is happier with it than jeffrey is
so let's hop back to this critical game
between tigran petrossian
and leni dominguez so we had a couple of
moves
lenny played rook f7 rook f1 takes takes
queen c7 and queen f2
destinedly setting up this threat of
bishop e6 and queen f8
m8 but the biggest problem is
that not only do you have to look out
for these mating ideas
you also have to deal with this d4 pawn
weakness
now if you would go ahead and take it
then there could be queen c2 but if
as far as i can see that
isn't that good for lenny
sadly because there's queen a7 takes
queen a7 and there's queen f7 these long
range moves and queen a7
is decisive between f7
not only you will have your king in
check
queen f8 background mates are
on the 4. this is actually
looking quite bad for dominguez
let's see if tigran finds the move
if queen f4 however you can always go
queen c7
and just defend the seventh
while ground this thinking let's take a
look at what's going on
in fabiano's game
so it sort of got locked up we left it
off over
here fabi play knight g4 h3
knight e5 b5 and slowly but surely he's
getting out his bishop
f4 f6 now f6 is not a great move
in usual cases but in the timeline of
some sometimes
you can get away with it goes f5 and
make sure there's no
entry squares g6 should be seven
king f7 knight e2 c5 and suddenly as
this
bishop comes into play black is doing
fine and there'll be some targets
on h4 d8 not f3
take sticks and even though it's an
opposite
colored middle game there will be some
targets against
h i mean targets on h4 and f4 however
fabi will have to look out for some
cheapos with rook g1 and bishop h5
c4 rook g1 rook g8 king h2
this bishop actually is doing some fine
job over
there but this queen sort of needs to
find a better square somehow
now we cannot just take on d1 because
bishop takes
and then the aforementioned bishop takes
h5
actually becomes a problem b4
so he could be preparing something like
c3
putting pressure on the c2 pawn
or or something like b3 after a5
a4 note that taking isn't really helping
white a whole bunch because they'll be
bishop h for ideas
and an extra pawn is still an extra pawn
even if it's an opposite
colored metal game bishop e2 trying to
press
this pawn
something like a5 a4 would make sense
one thing that would be great for
fabi to avoid is something like b3 and
bishop c4
where this bishop would become a monster
and very annoying
bishop c5 was played
rook f1
and even though the position is still
more or less balanced
fabiano does have a two-minute advantage
on the clock
so that is still a very good
sign rook g2 now rook g2 is claiming
that he's going to be aggressive on the
g
file and gives up the default d file for
better or
worse so maybe something like taking
queen d1
when the eight makes sense and try to
pressure on the h pawn
as there's no clear counter play on the
d file
since this bishop takes away the g1
square
so what i'm sort of expecting is
something like takes
queen d8 and bishop e7 looking for
complications
in that direction
and last but not least sadvani is
threatening
to take on c4 after rook takes d8 so
this is a threat
of taking ambition takes c4
fabi is in a deep tank there
which is completely understandable this
is a big decision
he did take on d1 just driving the
bishop away
can you go bishop d4 well in that case
c3
queen defends from the side and these
ideas of building
batteries just doesn't work so he does
go for this idea of queen d8
hitting that bishop taking away that
square
sort of anticipate bishop e7 and he did
play that
and even though white will have some
play
the black i mean the white king can be
in
wait is queen d for an idea
pin d4 takes takes takes takes here
king h1 unfortunately
it does not work for
fabiano queen b6
but he is actually just a move away if
he gets
to pose the queen on d4 that can
become decisive rook d2 trying to get
in there on d7 but is there something
like g5 because anytime you check
i just move my king away and we'll have
queen f2 bishop g3 ideas
so in fact g5 might be a monstrous
idea but wait g5 then there's takes so
that's no good
rook d8 just keeping it
solid but that shouldn't
really surprise you because even without
brooks
white has more targets in his position
plus the king is a bit
vulnerable so even after a rook exchange
fabi can go for g5 breaks and
there is some possibilities of winning
that position
queen f2 bishop takes wow
and suddenly the king is in danger that
is something
that i was kind of referring to bishop
b6
with big threats i kind of assume queen
d5 is the move
trying to go and get the queen back to
g2
but if all of the queen takes b4
cold-blooded
okay
let's jump back in this game
all right we're back so queen takes b4
queen f3 king g1
and even though there's no checks
you still have to be careful with
this position
queen d4
there queen g3 king f1
queen e1 king g2
king g1 bishop g3
just creating a deadly net
ship g3 bishop c4 bishop
he goes bishop b3
there
now bishop h2 does not do a whole lot
check check and the king has to run this
way
checking f1 takes
queen g2
king d3 in fact there is
this brutal hawking c3 runs into bishop
e1 and it's
a queen that is going to be
a queen should be one check
if you go here bishop f2 bishop
here is worse because bishop f2 bishop
e3
is winning and that's an important win
by fabiano wins the game
let's take a look at the remaining games
between
wesley so
and marti rossian she's up two pawns
the question is if he can freeze these
pawns on
e4 and f3 but
objectively this should be when he might
just walk around
down there e5 and even if you take
the e pawn is just too fast
there king f6 and the pawn is
used as a shelter and a shield for the
king
and once you push it down there this is
again an interesting
technique by wesley sometimes you can
cross and just cut off the king
sideways here king e6 and there's no
stopping and even if you go here rook e5
and then there is a total of a totem
pole of pieces
rookie one rookie five and
it is complete domination but obviously
they didn't play these moves which means
that the first round has been won by
the st louis archbishops which
is a very important step for them
for the road to the
repeat because the archbishops are
obviously
the reigning champions and this would be
their second win in a row
if they do so yes all the games are over
yes so one game that
we did not see the end of
was between dominguez
and tigran petrossian
which i am not certain of that result
so let's have a quick look
of what happened in this game
we left it off earlier on
king f7 b3
the whole point is is to get the knight
to c4 you might have a
and might get a doubled pawn in this
position however what matters is your
majority on the king side
a6 rook d three bishop d6
c5 knight c4 and because of this
pressure
black is forced to capture takes king e6
h4 gaining some space which is always
important whenever you're playing chess
to get more space b5 rook c3
takes 6 b4 takes takes rook d5
and this is a typical scenario where
even though black also has a majority on
the queen side
but the mite pieces are actually
taking a hold of the important entry
squares of c5 and a5
and might even pressure some of these
weak pawns on a6 and c7
okay 8 rook a5 c6 bishop b6
again just keeping all of black's pieces
out of sight king d7
king f1 and never forget this
is an end game so you want your king to
participate
king c8 bishop c5 and this is actually a
sudden move a sudden shift
the king actually walked too far from
the e5 pawn and vastly so as a vastly so
for a reason
a super gm he knows when it's time to
exchange
king c7 takes 6 king e2
and oftentimes you get these end games
and you think that
all of these rook end games are just
drawn not
at all especially if your rook
is condemned to defend a measly pawn on
a6
while your king is stranded defending
the e5 pawn
h6 h5 no wonder that the computer says
it's plus one right now so it's a
one pawn advantage roughly for white
g5 hg rook g8 rook takes a6
takes g3 and this is a whole lot of an
accomplishment
for wesley he is up upon and still has
clear targets on the queen side
h5 a3 decides to exchange it off
instead but that's also a good strategy
because
that wasn't the only weakness there's
also somewhat
isolated pawn on h5 h4
rook d3 king e6 rook c3 king d6
now the point of h3 h5 h4
is in case of taking there's rook g4
double attacking
but sd does not seem to mind
rook g4 f3 rook takes king d2
and wesley did bring this rook to d3 for
a reason
now this king on d3 is cut off
so if he manages to somehow start
pushing
the c pawn and then gobble up that c6
pawn
this will be a technically one position
h2 king c3 rook f2 king b3
here rook c3 rook takes
and here wesley thought that this king
is offsides enough for me to get into
that exchange
and i can also activate my king
in the meanwhile takes king f4
check king c4 heading towards
the second pawn and as a rule of thumb
if you get two pawns connected
in a rocking game most of the time you
are
winning and so is the case in
this one as well rook takes king d5
king takes ok 5 check king d4
f5 rook b6 check
e5 and as we said earlier on
there's no stopping the epon
as the king is caught off
after rook a5
and the king himself is going
to escort that pawn and turn it into
her majesty a lady it's an important win
an important win by wesley and
not jeffrey but wesley
and caruana so the score is two and a
half one and a half
in round one so that means
that lenny dominguez did go down to
tigran petrossian's attack
but regardless st louis
is in the lead so
the armenia eagles will have to
come back and fight in round two and
three if you
if they still want to be in contention
for first place
but we'll see if that happens
and meanwhile we are going to take a
short little break
see you soon in round two
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the u.s chess championships
and the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills and increased
confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than
100 schools providing hundreds of
classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame
this one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience
chess in imaginative ways and is home to
the us and world chess
halls of faint cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art
innovative programming explores the
intersection of chess art
and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame is nothing you
expect
and everything you love three different
galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st
louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
do
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st
louis slough attracts students and
professors from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team
on the very first year of the team's
inception slu obtained second best
university at the pan american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st louis
university
that was an amazing piece
the opposition has never been as needed
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the us chess championships and
the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to children throughout
the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the u.s and world chess
halls of faint
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
hello and welcome back to round two of
the world championship protest league
final between the st louis archbishops
and the armenia eagles the first round
did go really well for the
saint louis team with a two and a half
one and a half
win in round one but round two
is coming up shortly with
some important action
as we all know this is a four round
event
and the first who reaches eight and a
half points
wins the whole series and in fact
as you might know this would be
the second victory in a row for
the archbishops as
the st louis team comes off as
the title holders coming into this final
first of i would say that the armenians
did come up with
a strategy they were trying to
neutralize all
their blackboards but that quite didn't
quite
work for them even though tigran
petrossian
did go all out versus dominguez
and succeeded in winning
however it did backfire versus
fabiano and vastly so
which means that they're now in the
lead so let's talk about round two with
fabiano taking on tigran petrossian
with white lenny dominguez facing radh
ranak sadvani para maksudu facing off
as white versus wesley so hayek
playing white versus jeffrey jung
and this is going to be a critical round
the armenians will have to fight back if
they want to claim stake for the title
by the way you can follow these games
online if you hit
slash follow on chess.com
as this match and this tournament is
held online even though the chess party
as they so call it
was supposed to happen in norway but
for unfortunate reasons it got relegated
to being played online but
the round has started so let's take a
look at the marquee match-up
between fabiano carana and tigran
petrossian
so this is the game let me pull up
the other games as well
so back to this game
it is an aggressive line played by
fabiano the bishop g5 line
which is the big hype these days seen it
being played
at the st louis rapidom blitz tournament
this one is actually aiming for quick
development i assume
c4 is going to happen as fabiano
is aiming for an aggressive play
black has a solid structure this
triangle structure
however there's still plenty of pieces
on the 8th still undeveloped
and therefore black will have to be in
time
to get them all out before the attack
comes about
knight f3 is actually an interesting
move by fabiano
not only does he defend the d2 knight he
also kind of
prepares knight g5 which as a damocles
sword
will threaten queen h7 which will always
linger in the air castle possibly
f6 is an idea
however that does look very
dangerous with the king still in the
middle
but again if you castle short that can
be an
issue a3 was played
so both sides are very very well
prepared for this game
and the question is whether he wants to
take this knight or just drop back
i would assume dropping back to e7
is the more solid approach but let's
take a look around and let's
continue our journey on the board
between parhamov that is maxulou
and grandmaster vastly so
so we've got a very classical
opening queen's gambit declined played
by wesley
ship g5 h6 bishop h4 and the not so
classical
d takes c4 most everybody castles here
but dtx c4 is known to be vishy anand
the legend the world champion's
favorite little path line which now
wesley tries out
queen c2 knight d5 trying to get
this semitarosh kind of position
take sticks e4 take stakes b5
a4 bishop b7 and a6
so maxullu actually gave up a pawn
however he does have
the central control so if anything that
can be a source of compensation
the question is if maksudu can go b3
because if you capture on back with cb
then there's a takes b5 and white will
retain the center
as p3 was played
on the other hand don't forget the king
of parham is still stuck on e1
so wesley noticing that goes and quickly
castles
possibly b4 or c5 could
make a difference and with
maxullus pieces being rather scattered
this looks like a promising position for
wesley would not consider taking on c4
because that would actually help parham
to castle b4 indeed
queen e3 trying to hold the fort
and now either e5 or c5 but somehow c5
feels more natural b5 just trying to
keep it closed
if d takes c5 that could run into knight
d7
rook c8 and black
clearly has an advantage so d5 is the
only practical try
that maksudu can go for
so with the white king still in the
center even
outrageous moves as f5
is coming into considerations but even
if you think about it
it is the archbishops who are
leading with one point so f5
might be a little bit too outrageous at
the moment
with a score like two and a half one and
a half
however a win is still a win so if you
want to win this before round three
you might as well go for f5 knight d7
a very solid choice by wesley which
might not be
the most critical move but is very
logical connecting the rooks
and you can always play f5 later
so parham puts the bishop on d3 exactly
for that reason
he could have gone bishop e2 but that
wouldn't hold off
important squares c takes d5
and we possibly gonna see a sharp game
f5 very nice move by wesley
if white goes and takes there then
nestle can take on e3 go bishop d5 and
have
a more or less comfortable position in
the end game
with two passers on c5 and b4
even something like takes queen f6 comes
into consideration however if ef
queen f6 then there's castles
i could also consider something like
castling
because if takes knight takes you might
be able to actually go
for the pawn sack goes rookie
eight and this is getting actually very
sharp
because if black opens up the position
the b1 h7 diagonal might
be very annoying to deal with
rookie e8 sort of expecting
something like rookie one
so even though plaque has an
interesting position should be
objectively fine there's some
dangers lurking because the king is not
yet as
safe with moves f7 f5
we'll come back to this one but first
off let's take a look at
hike marti rossian games versus jeffrey
zhang
so jeffrey is facing off
a unique line e3 castle
this is called the hebden variation
should be e5
f6 c6 knight c3 takes takes knight c7
and even though black has the bishop
pair it's a closed position so it is not
that easy
to use them or not yet and d2
e5 so it's clear that marti rossian is
aiming for
something unbalanced and strange
now this position is strange
for sure should be six f4
trying to start storming with the pawns
with
f4 and g4
c5 trying to open it up king b1
a5 a4 a3 takes takes f5
knight b5 but as far as i can see
after c5
is in big danger you can't really take
that pawn
because you just get checkmated on the b
file
so instead he says take my pawn i will
try to get
counter play elsewhere but i'm not going
to open up
the b file for your rooks so from a
practical
standpoint this is actually quite a good
choice
by him question what
jeffrey thinks so you can go for the
pawn
or try to trap that bishop on
b5 with that bishop having
no way back however if
that bishop won't be captured then
going c4 would go counter to the plans
of black in these type of positions you
want to open it up
at all costs that's why he went for a5
a4 and c5
but if you win the piece then you might
as well can go for it takes
takes c4
but possibly there's something like
knight a2 knight c3
and with these bishops being a little
passive i'm not sure
if that is that good now knight eight
was a mysterious move
possibly he wants to get that knight to
e4
however he could have just won a pawn
that takes and bishop takes d4
instead he goes for this maneuver
which seems quite slow
but okay this seems like a safe idea
so martirosian decides to go towards e5
however that does allow knight e4
not that black's position is worse or
anything
but there could have been something
more advantageous for jeffrey zhang
c8 just taking away all jumps
there's no g4 breaks right now because
just f takes g
and knight e4 is common
queen e3
but looking at this position black
is starting to run out of ideas
you can't really go knight e4 because
you have to face g4
h5 is not an option you always have to
10 for the g
pawn c4 doesn't help you because that
just closes off
the queen side although
maybe going c4 rook k5 b5 b4
could be an idea
but this does look strategically
very risky for black with these bishops
actually just facing the wall
knight e4 but i'm sort of worried about
ideas such as g4
in any case we are going to take a look
what's going on
in dominguez's game versus sadhuani
another another
good old berlin
ship b4 bishop e6 g4
a typical idea if white manages to walk
up the king
to g3 then you are doing good
knight e7 knight d4 b3
again trying to smoke out that bishop on
d5
b5 bishop g3 and f4 bishop c3
and here sadvani offered a draw
to leni dominguez
now rook b1
it's still a very complicated position
h takes knight takes d5
but now it's a big decision
for dominguez to make he can take a draw
if he'd
like to as other boards don't look too
bad
the one that is sort of pending is with
marty rossian versus jeffrey zhang
however a win would
be a very very good result
for dominguez is his thinking let's take
a look
how he responds to this clever draw
offer
objectively black should be all right
but chess is not just evaluations it's
about
psychology
and in fact with a lead
on the board the draw isn't necessarily
a bad result now rook b1
could be considered or maybe even knight
takes d5
because if you take i can take knight c7
and win the exchange
so knight d5 might actually be an idea
as well
actually takes knight takes c6 and maybe
an exchange sack
although that does look a little bit
far-fetched
might actually work
so let's take a look back to wesley's
game
versus maxudo
we left it off over here queen d6
rookie 8 rookie 7 bishop b3
and now it's getting dangerous because
if these pawns start rolling black will
be in trouble
in g6 ef takes fgo
that looks like looks like a
bad mistake by wesley here just
losing the pawn rook d3
rook e7 ship c8
kf2 knight f6 bishop f5
so if wesley manages to pick up that
pawn
even though king is still a little bit
iffy on h8
you still have to tend for the d-pawn
so it is still kind of annoying position
and meanwhile the game between dominguez
and sadvani did end in a draw so let's
go
back
rook e5 i would assume bishop takes g6
has to be played
bishop c2 trying to win it
takes bishop c2 rook d8
wow so he's saying you can take my
exchange
a la petrossian but i am going to start
pushing my cnb
pawns and you might regret your decision
of taking it
so wesley has two minutes 10 seconds to
maxulous to
43.
possibly even ideas such as d6
could make some sense trying to win the
c pawn
and then gobble the b1
so actually d6 does make some sense
all right let's take a look at fabi's
game next
as that is going to be also
very critical to round two
fabiano is
down upon with less space
which means he's in some sort of trouble
if the screen ever gets to g4 and h3
then there'll be problems
so let's backtrack a little bit what
happened
we left off around here queen b1
rook d8 bishop g5 and the only issue
with bishop being on g5 you never get
this knight g5
n b4 knight e4
cd knight takes h6 rook takes d5
and from strength these pawns
can actually become weaknesses so fabi
decides to give it back
give the pawn to black that is
we need two takes and it turns out
just being down upon
g5 rook e4
sort of planning something along the
lines of rook g4
queen d3 now you must go queen e1 but in
that case there's queen d1
and that looks like an uncomfortable end
game
so this actually looks very very dodgy
for fabiano
queen d3 yep queen queen e1
then queen d1 and if black is precise
this looks like a tough position
maybe rook g4 trying to go for knight g5
and try to
muddy waters also he has 17 seconds
versus 154 which is kind of
a problem i guess king h5 is annoying
because g4 g3 is coming
and that also sets up the mating ideas
this
is looking ugly for fabiano sadly
g4 and h2
g3
okay three setting up these checks
rook a2 is also quite tough to handle
rook c4 check
knight e1
if he manages to wriggle out somehow
trying to get some checks but rook a2 is
quite a strong move
pressing on that square
king g6
knight d3 rook d2 and that is
nasty and petrossian wins
which is actually equalizing the score
so far three three so let's take a look
how is
jeffrey zhang doing versus mkhitaryan
check so they've been
repeating v1 queen a3
hayek decides to make a run for it
and with this king being
very very iffy on g7 black might be
in danger honestly it's still a
double-edged position
so it's anyone's game but um
but this king seems to be a bit much
a bit weaker than its counterpart queen
h3
this might have ran into queen g5
here check here
check check and checkmate
but queen d4 throws it away king g8
and now it's very very very
interesting this king is suddenly much
more
of a pickle and has 19 seconds worth
versus 30 seconds
queen f1 is notably a checkmate
in a3 you can block because rook e1 is
kind of
an issue now queen f3 is at least
a draw rookie one
king b2 probably repetition is correct
well let's see what jeffrey decides to
do
honestly i don't see anything more than
a draw and probably
it will end in a draw and they did reach
a draw
so it boils down to the last game
between maxulou
and wesley with
white having an extra pawn but this
should
technically be a draw however
it's 35 seconds versus 20 seconds
so it's not that simple
knight f2 knight f7
king d3
and something like the h3 is a good
little move yep
because even though black would get
to be two pawns down but it's a double h
pawn and if you have a king in front of
it it's a draw
now this is a simple draw you just need
to give up your knight for that pawn
and that would be a draw first
wesley declined the offer i think out of
inertia
but then parkham of that is maxullu
offered to draw
yet again and now it is tied
actually it's not tied yet now let's tie
four two four with
uh win by tigran petrossian
and the next around
14 minutes we'll start
a bit later so this was a big comeback
by the armenian
armenian eagles holding off all
three boards and with petrossian
actually
winning the game versus fabiano caruana
so all that said the score now
is four to four with
an important match up in round three
so round three is crucial
as we're getting two words
and heading towards the big round
four final match up
so the games are going to start n120
um
so let's take a quick peek
of what happened in this jeffrey game
um let's switcheroo
quickly we go here takes queen a3
and here correctly
marti rossian decides to continue the
game
rogue d2 rookie 8 queen f4 queen h3
and sometimes we are a bit more
concerned with safety
than with checkmating but here queen g5
would have been decisive
if i'm correct or maybe rook d7
check and king d2 and there's
mate i originally thought queen g5
is the issue but after king f8 i do not
see a way
let's just check and indeed rook d7
would have been the killer blow
for martirossian and even though you
could
munch on this b1 rook it won't
taste that good after queen f7 and
checkmate on g7
so here rook d7 was a big chance
but it was missed oh it was missed
played queen d4 instead king g8
and one slip is enough in these sharp
positions
if you find the right move you might win
the game
one slip and it's gone king c1
and here jeffrey
correctly sunk into a deep think
but there was nothing better
than a draw funnily enough
black has such a big compensation that
the that even the awkward queen a8
would hold the draw threatening queen
h1 checkmate but
it would still boil down to a draw after
king c1
queen a3
so we are going to take
a short little break and we'll be back
with
round three
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the us chess championships and
the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills and increased
confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the us and world chess
halls of faith
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries
and a premier gift shop highlight the
culture history
and creativity behind the game come
visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus
visit stlchestcampus.org
my
do
we should move
so
that was an amazing piece
easily dominating these rivals when in
game after game the opposition has never
been as needed
in the world
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value
chess brings to our community in these
times of social distancing it's more
important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
one stay
safe and continue to watch play and
enjoy the game of chess
so
hello and welcome back everyone for the
protest league
finals with the saint louis archbishops
facing
the armenia eagles and
both of are the team both teams are
actually
undefeated and the score is as expected
tied so we've got some matches going on
we start off with the match between
the high comma mater versus fabiano
caruana
now this is an important matchup as
karana
lost to tigran petrossian the previous
round so
might as well be the most critical
matchup of this round let's take a look
at what's
going on so
as we have seen earlier between
yuyongi and karana he played the
a6 variation and yet again we have
c5 so it seems that marti rossian
is very much confident that he can hold
this position with
white and leave the other players
to do the dirty work queen e2
now do not underestimate these positions
white
does have a little pressure here and a
little pressure there
but objectively white is not really
ambitioning more than half a point p5
very aggressive move by fabiano
but even after a4 b4 knight e2 a5
the position is still closer
to a draw than anything else
in fact even here e5 could make sense
just exchange on a5 queen takes e5
and that might be a symbolic advantage
for white but
nothing too much knight b6 played
knight e5 maybe maybe hoping to get that
knight
bolstered after f4
and i wonder what marty rossian will do
and he does go for
f4 which is an ambitious choice because
the e3 pawn
can become weakness just as you
can see in many other similar positions
in the stone wall
but let's take a look around and let's
take a look at wesley sew
facing off versus ronak saddavani
so let's go there with wesley playing
white he's playing the solid
g3 system against the slav
and they kind of get into
some slow moving waters
i can see that both teams are looking
for a
slow burner they are not trying to burn
all bridges anymore
they want to fight and postpone the
fight
for the time trouble slash middle game
middle game first then the time trouble
phase
rook d1 so anytime you get these
positions you
always have to decide whether you want
to get your rook on the c file and the d
file or would you want to get your rook
on d1 and e1 preparing an e4
break queen c7 and queen c7 actually
makes a lot of sense
with wesley already deciding to put a
rook on d1
queen c7 is logical because you would
have to waste an
extra move to go back and hassle that
lady
on c7
e4 could be an idea however at the end
of the day
that can run into c5s and the queen
would be under attack so your wesley is
wondering if he should go e4 now or
should he prepare it first
so let's leave him pondering a little
bit he actually did take on
d5 which makes sense
as c takes d5 would run into knight b5
winning an important tempo and bishop a3
would have some very annoying threats
set up so i kind of assume either knight
takes d5 or e takes d5
is the one that we should expect but in
this case the bishop is not as happy as
it would
after c takes a d5
in any case let's take a look
at domain guesses game
versus maxodlo this is
the main line known from
the anand kasparov matches
the main main line that is 94. the
dominguez playing
the open spanish queen d5
so far theory but it does seem that
dominguez is more booked up maxullu has
seven minutes
to lenie is eight thirty-four
queen d5 and kind of what we know
in these type of positions if
white doesn't get a quick initiative
going
the game often just fizzles out in a
draw
knight takes d4 that sort of seems to be
the move head in towards the draw than
anything
else
question is whether the move is queen d4
queen e4 queen e4 possibly would just
drop a pawn with
a b does that even drop a pawn
that doesn't even drop a pawn because
the queen
does defend that rook back
so let's head back towards
jeffrey's game which we haven't looked
at at all
jeffrey is facing the perk
a petrossian favorite
but jeffrey is unperturbed he goes
for a good old classical spanish
approach
trying to just attack
these weakened a5 and e5 pawns
bishop a6 rook d1 ship takes rook takes
knight d2 and this knight actually
decides to head
towards the a pawn and press from there
now white's position isn't
so much better but it's much easier to
play
with the queen and knight
bothering that a pawn
queen b5 as expected was played
now rookie a6 would run into rook takes
d7
winning two pieces for the rook so that
is
unlikely to happen question
is if there's rook b8 and i think there
is
because if you capture here rook a6
the queen goes to c7 and rook c6 and i
see jeffrey shaking his head
realizing that actually this
isn't really leading to an advantage but
it does lead to a draw if
that is something he's looking for now
he wants to continue the fight
he can definitely drop back to d3 or e2
but queen a5 is just a repetition of
moves
both decision actually is legitimate
possibly queen a5 is the best move
however
queen e2 doesn't really spoil that much
the game is still around even
what will jeffrey decide
queen d3 indeed he decides
to continue the struggle knight b6
which is an interesting choice as these
bishops
ain't worth too much so even considering
about just taking it
and just claim that your bishop on g7
will not be a big participant of this
whole event
so wouldn't mind taking just getting the
rook in on the open files
possibly knight b6 was a little bit too
ambitious
and mike can hope for some smidgen of an
advantage
now queen b5 would be a terrible idea
because after knight c4
your queen would be trapped
sunlight takes rook takes rook c1
and white has a comfortable comfortable
position
i would love to take that knight because
if i go rook c1 early on then there's
knight a4 and that pawn on a4
is hanging so liquidating this attacker
does seem to make a lot of sense but
also i'm taking a look at the clock
situation with jeffrey having five
minutes versus seven
that isn't looking good and gives
some swindling opportunities for
petrossian
so we'll come back to this one but first
off let's take a look
what's happening in the mkhitaryan that
is high quality rossian
fabiano caruana game
so we left it off around here and
fabi decides to smoke out that knight on
e5
knight e8 knight b1 lots of maneuvering
going on
here white is hoping to get this
knight out of there but it seems that
fabiano is quicker
not f3 knight f5 you've got to
do something otherwise you lose the pawn
if you would take here
dc and this bishop would become a
monster so obviously marti rossian
doesn't want any of that takes ef
but that actually means that there's
always a constant target
on e3 and i know that people usually con
them
doubled pawns but this is actually a
dream team
holding off important squares on e4 and
e5
and d2 rook e8 targeting the e
pawn while this knight is heading
towards c5
hit b3 take 6 knight c5
bishop c6 so here white argues that yes
i gave up this week e pawn however
your advantage of pawns is a doubled
pawn
so it won't count that much but in
return i
do get a very nice knight on c5
also there are some trickies with rook
c4
with this rook being undefended
subjectively the position might still be
around
even however it is
still upon up for
fabiano rookie seven very nice move
just covering the seventh rank possibly
some maneuver of bishop e8 bishop f7
comes to mind just to avoid any trickery
after b3
also if you could get that knight to e4
that's the moment
you would have an amazing
position but
it will take some maneuvering for
fabiano to
actually convert so let's see how
maxullu is doing versus
lenie dominguez left it off here
check there takes queen e1
knight takes f4 and
it is an extra pawn for dominguez but
there's a raging attack brewing that
alone queen trying to hold off the
attack
and if you look at the clock that does
not look very inspiring
as dominguez has three minutes versus
moxo lose
six knight d4
threatening knight c2 and knight to b3
now white's main issue so far is that he
cannot really go queen h4
or queen e4 because there's a constant
piece hanging on f1
however something like f6
can be an idea but first of all you have
to deal with knight c2
i'd reckon something like bishop g5
makes sense
and if knight c2 just go queen g3
setting up bishop f6
threats and then just going for mate
possibly bishop g5 is the move
and if i know maksudu
correctly he is a big attacker and
does not shy away from giving up pieces
or exchanges if it comes to that
because bishop g5 knight c2 queen g3
takes you do have to capture though
and then king h8 so it does
something similar in case of knight c2
you could also go queen c1
if you don't want to part with the
exchange
because again if we see knight c2 queen
g3 knight takes a1
the screen again is attacking that rook
so you don't really have any time
to set up mating threats with the queen
on g3 and a pawn on f6
which you would definitely love to have
as white but here you can't do that
let's see what is going on with wesley's
game while they're thinking
in this position
lastly got what he wanted a very much
dominating position with this bishop
staring
at the wall
and sadvani as per his good old
tradition
offers a draw yet again but this time i
do not think that he'll be in luck and i
don't think that this will be
accepted as one has
a clear plan of eventually breaking
through with e4
and black has absolutely no plans over
here
just looking around you don't have this
idea of getting this knight to c4
maybe knight f6 knight e4 so not that
black doesn't have
a play but i do not see a reason
for white to accept it and as expected
leslie decides to continue ruxin
so might as well be setting up some
ideas of doubling or tripling on the c
pawn oftentimes you could even sacrifice
there
because you not only get the c pawn but
the d5
as well with multiple pawns
on the white squares
question is if knight f6 is an idea but
that
possibly would just run into knight e5
also it is a hefty time advantage for
white
as sadvani has two minutes versus
wesley's
340. rook c3 and indeed he is planning
to do the old triplo on
the c file
and it can get very ugly for
can get super ugly for sadwani
if he just does a single misstep
look here so i guess we
will not see a pseudo alakine's gun
it's going to be the real thing after
queen c1
and we see the original alkynes gone
by vastly so so now the question is
indeed where
should we put this knight one of the
ideas could be to get the knight to d3
play f4 and knight e5 and that could be
the reason why bestie
chose queen c1 set up compared to queen
c2 because in this case
f4 is possible in id5
he actually does not do it says
i'm gonna win this pawn
because if you capture back i just have
too much pressure on your rook
so presume some like queen b8 is what
the doctor would prescribe
for black but that does not mean
that wesley cannot go back go f4 and
knight
e5 which still looks like a magnificent
position
for wesley
so a completely justified decline
declination
or a completely
um good decision by wesley and justified
decision of
refusing the draw offered that seemed a
little bit suspect
with black having all his pieces
so much stranded
so let's see what siddvani is coming up
with
as far as i can see queen b8 is by far
the only move
queen f8 which i do not like because it
moves away from pieces
and here we see the sacrifice
knight to b8 and you can consider rook
c7 or even rook c5
and do a double exchange sack
because these rocks are so dominated it
really doesn't matter that they're on
the board it goes rook c7
i presume there'll be an exchange in
queen g7 trying to
get as many pieces off the board as
possible
and the only issue that wesley has to
face is this bishop being a little bit
passive
bishop g7 which i don't like this can
even run into ideas such as knight
h3 knight g5 but
leslie doesn't even go for that one
rook c8 sunlight queen b7
just pressing there and setting up some
ideas of bishop f7
wesley might just clutch this one up
yep queen b7 pressing there pressing on
that but now bishop f7
bishop g6 just curtains
as everything is falling in sadvani's
position
yep bishop f7 and it is game
vastly so so that actually opens up the
books
for the archbishops and now
there is a one zero lead for st
louis so let's take a look what's going
on in this game
because this is also critical rook
e6 now queen h6 there's always queen f8
however you can tell that black is in
big trouble if you have only one move
to a threat like queen h6
something like rook c one made sense and
also
dominguez has no time queen c4
rook g1 king h8 that
does leave
does leave black mated because
after rook g8 there's rook f7 and it is
checkmate
that means that it is all tied up so
let's take a look at
the second most critical game between
fabiano corona
and hike marti rossian so
fabiano is still nursing his advantage
of that extra pawn but this bishop is
still quite kind of
passive on c6
so the question is whether he will be
able
to break through this fortress knight d4
king c7
rook a6 rook a5 is an idea but
he tries to stay solid however if this
bishop
gets here then there'll be problems
so jeffrey did end up drawing tigran
petrossian
so we are left with this game with
all tied
so karana has 21 seconds with versus 40
but with an extra pawn
so this should be a win but there's some
technical difficulties and with this
bishop being clumsy
it is not as simple as
any barb would show you knight c2
so like the rookie e4 could make sense
king d2
obviously you have to sidestep that
threat
and timing is key in these type of
positions
if you push the d-pawn too early it
might actually become a target
probably just king c5 or
rookie two king there you've got to go
bishop c4 because there's a cheapo
and now he is in this
should be a win c5
and sometimes even bishop b3 becomes an
ita ghost king c7 rook f6
and there goes one pawn knight d4 rook
g2
just eyeing this pawn and suddenly
because of this
clumsy bishop black definitely will
face some troubles king here
king c6 then the bishop moves
king d6 and suddenly knight c6 is a big
big threat
knight c6 and that's mate
this actually is turning around
fabi is in big big trouble
there check king f8
it takes
and this is still
possibly holdable possibly if
fabiano manages to set up something like
a fortress but it's unlikely especially
after king f6
and that will just win all those spawns
and that looks very very dicey
for archbishops
takes and there's not much
you can do now if takes that would be a
big mistake because d2
and promotion king e5
let's see how marty rossian continues
rook b4
f7 and your fabi is planning to activate
that king
so it ain't that simple and time is
ticking
time is ticking you still can't take
cause palm push
and it ain't clear anymore it ain't
clear anymore
this might just be
holdable by now with the d-pawn
coming so close
there king goes there you cannot ever
take because
d to wait you can take d2
check check take take
is actually winning so this rook takes
f5
just came in time for
marti rossian and he's winning again
f6 king f5 here
you still can't
promote f7 and king up
therein just takes looks
a lot like a fortress still
there king e6 and there's no difference
just repeat
and it's not not clear
what hike can do f7
king e7 wins the pawn
the king is cut off but
no time for either side
and very gritty defense by
fabiano very gritty defense
f3
and you can't quite win this pawn
without taking there
because d2 d1 is a strong threat
and probably marti rossian is going to
make a draw and draw agreed with the
match
being tied six to six with
one round to go
crazy crazy games
big win by maxulou and wesley so
and that means that we're going to have
an
all decisive fourth round and if not
and at the end of the day if it's tight
then we're going to head off towards tie
breaks
so the last round one plays one
two plays two board three plays board
three
and four four so fabiano caron versus
dominguez against hayek marti rossian so
they'll be playing
white versus maksudu and martijn
respectively tigran petrossian faces
versus wesley so and ronak's advani
is going to be white versus jeffrey
zhang
so that'll be the last round and if
still tied
we are going to see a tiebreaker
for the championship title
and now we are going to have a small
little break and then we'll be back with
the final round
stay tuned
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world
and plays host to all major tournaments
including the us chess championships
and the sinkfield cup one of the
strongest chess tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills and increased
confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the us and world chess
halls of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries
and a premier gift shop highlight the
culture history
and creativity behind the game come
visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus
visit stlchestcampus.org
my
do
we should move
so
that was an amazing piece of calculation
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
so
so
so
so
hello and welcome back and let's take a
quick
look at the pairings between the saint
louis archbishops
and the armenian eagles as they're tied
heading towards
the last round of the pro
chess league this is round four where
number one is going to be facing
number one number two versus number two
and so on and so forth with
which most of the boards st
louis being the favorite but favorite is
not enough in sports as the match is
tied right now
so we see corona facing off versus
maxudo
dominguez playing against hike marti
rossian
with uh tigran petrossian facing wesley
so as white
ranak sadvani is facing jeffrey
zhang as a white so let's head in
on to the big marquee matchup between
corona and maxo lou and it is
a spanish let's see if it's your
ordinary spanish
or something that we call the marshall
actually it is just a classic spanish
that we see castles avoiding that line
and
i kind of wonder if you're going to see
something like the breyer
no the good old smee slope variation
we're trying to put pressure on the e4
pawn
as a black we should be seven and here
plenty of moves
a4 knight d2 but fabiano is
choosing the classical setup famously
seen
between anand and adam's
very famous match where adams
was destroyed by a prepared novelty
by the legendary world champion vichy
anand
ship c2 and
a couple of ways of playing these
positions you can take
c takes knight b4 c5 that
is actually the sharpest way of playing
and is the mainland or h6
and here fabiano goes for d5 a more
positional approach
he could have also tried a4
b3 and here white is aiming to build a
marotzias
structure which is quite solid and the
whole point is
that you're walling up that bishop on b7
even though sometimes you do get some
pawn weaknesses
on c4 so let's say bc bc
the pawn on c4 can become a target
however it's not that easy to reach it
a5 same idea trying to eventually
use this bishop and target the
weakened c4 pawn
bishop e3 and bishop e3 is actually a
very nice little move
by fabiano he is discouraging knight c5
because they can't always be taken
also setting up ideas such as knight d2
over defending the c4 square and the e4
square
and keeping knight g3 up as an option
let's take a look at board two
there is um
lenny dominguez martirossian
is a classical
berlin
nothing spectacular still known theory
it is considered to be rather even
but it's not yet over
tigran petrossian game so again we see
a king's indian attack with vastly
pushing
all his pawns on the queen side
d2 rook c8 h5 h6
knight g4 rookie rook c1
and a big question is whether a
sacrifice by
white is enough for a draw or
is it good at all in fact
it can become quite dangerous
so it feels and seems like bishop f8 or
knight f8 knight h7
could be called off for that king h7
saying if you take take queen takes
the queen and bishop is holding this
square on g5
and as long as you can't really throw
all my
all your pieces at me i will be doing
fine a very tense position with
which every result is still possible
let's take a look at jeffrey zhang's
game
it was again a taimanov a6
d5 knight f6
and we get an end game which is
considered
slightly better for white but now not by
a whole lot
should be 7 b3 rook d8 a3 a5
rook d1 and the position is more or less
even as white really doesn't have any
clear plans
of moving forward and black has a solid
extra pawn in the making because you
will get that extra space that is
let's go back to the game between maxodo
and caruana take 6 bishop a6
b4 and as you might have noticed
in these type of positions your main
goal is to keep this bishop
that white squared bishop locked in so
take six
who takes b for rook c four a three
typical little move which makes sure
that
again that bishop cannot get out take
stakes
knight b6 knight c4 queen e2
g6 rook a1 and this is the typical
spanish torture that everyone is trying
to avoid
you really don't have any active plans
left
and there's always a b5 pawn to look
after
knight d7
and here comes the big question whether
you want to play knight
d2 but fabiano decides to go knight f1
preparing to knight d2 to play knight d2
next
pressuring this knight and as we talked
about it
if this knight is gone there'll be a
clear target on b5
no wonder that maxulou is trying to
create a fortress over there trying to
avoid
that scenario
so even though fabiano has an advantage
here
there's still some hard work to be done
to win
so apart from actually pressuring here
you can also
maneuver the knight to a5 and then get
to c6 and in fact knight takes e3 was
an inaccuracy and i'll tell you why
because in these positions knights are
just much
stronger especially if they have an
outpost after this exchange
there's no one really blocking this
pressure on b5
and after knight a5 knight c6 even if
you take out my knight
i will have a very juicy square on d5
so this does look very comfortable
for white let's take a look at
this game between hayek martirossion and
leni dominguez rook h1 rook
g8 so martirosen is keeping some rooks
on the board
which might seem surprising but possibly
he didn't want to
get that rook in the h file
however if dominguez manages
to hold the grip on the king side
this will be an extra pawn to the good
as these pawns are doubled on the other
side so
let's say c5 you can go knight f5 and
every exchange would favor
white and with two pawns in the middle
there is a good chance for right to
press more
and black is cooling for a draw
so something like g6 makes sense taking
away that square
and then preparing c5
even then white can
switch gears go bishop f4 target the c7
pawn
and prepare something like e6
and in the long run you can even
maneuver this knight
to e4 up to f6 and that's why people
don't like pushing pawns too much
you create targets and that opposite
colored
bishop end game is not at all drawn
as white has so many
pawns on the king side there is chances
for dominguez to win there
so this is looking good for dominguez
karana is pressing
against maxudu but let's see what's
going on
in the petrossian wesley so game
so wesley played king h7
tigran petrossian play bishop h3 bishop
f8 knight h2
and this is actually a peculiar idea he
is
planning to start storming
wesley's king side as quickly as he can
knight e7 and g4 d4
opening it up for the bishop setting up
for some counter play also setting up
this
potential battery g5
knight d5 bishop g2 queen e7
so anytime if you take you just take
back
and just hold firm bishop g3 queen d8
knight g4 knight c3
and a big question in most of these
positions
is whether white has enough to break
through
it's either checkmate or you lose type
of positions
black actually holds the positional
advantage with this pawn being weak
black having more space however
there's so many pieces lingering on the
king side for white that black has to be
always on the lookout for any tactical
tricks
so g takes g takes one of the ideas is
knight g5
but then you would just take and then
you get
a position where are no more attacking
chances which would mean
a clear edge for black so no wonder it
does
petrossian go queen f4 if queen e7
bishop h4 and surprisingly the queen is
trapped
jeffrey has declined
let's take a look at jeffrey's game
on move 20 saddvani surprised us
with a draw offer and a
not so surprising declinal by jeffrey
zhang
right takes b6 rook takes b6 a4 and the
position is roughly even
but it does not mean that you cannot
continue playing
rook b8 bishop d6 and then actually it
is very reasonable
as jeffrey does outrage his opponent by
200 rating points
over the board ship takes rook takes
king d7
rook b4 edcd and edcd
seems like a concession that should have
been
shouldn't have been done by sadvani
because
this actually gives targets on the cnb
file
so earlier you could argue that the
positions around
even but now actually jeffrey does have
some targets in the position
rook h1 you can always go h6
and jeffrey still has a free reign so
he's
probably the only one pressing in this
position
so we have checked on all of the games
but let's just go back to
the vastly game as wesley
decided to take upon
on a2 and give up an exchange
knight d2 and this is actually getting
very
sharp over here because
not only is vastly threatened to lose an
exchange
but his opponent is threatening to
come on in with an attack this looks
very dodgy for black to be honest with
you
i'm not sure if this is
that comfortable or if it's holdable
even
for vastly so it's unlike rook g1
seems like a strong idea but as we've
seen earlier
super grand masters has likes of caruana
and wesley so they are real fighters
so if anyone then wesley can
hold this game
the only issue is that this pin is quite
strong and even after you lose the
exchange
it's not that the attack is dying down
especially rook g1 king h1 and there'll
be pressure
on the g file
knight d5
still looking uncomfortable
for black you even have to look out for
knight d6 ideas and knight takes f7 if
the king goes to h8
it kind of shows how difficult wesley's
position
is
queen f3 which is a strange decision i
did not see anything wrong with queen e4
check
can you go f5 ef knight takes takes
takes
so that was actually possible to go f5
and just cover
but queen f8 actually still allows
bishop takes e7
which doesn't look good for bestly
all right so let's take a look back at
the game
between saddvani and jeffrey zhang
rook c3 exchanging more pieces which is
logical
and he is actually coming up with a very
interesting plan
king b2 and he plays where he is
strongest and that is the queen side
c3 king a3 b4
and suddenly white does get
lively play as these spawns are
slowly going to start rolling down the
board
not saying that black should be in
an immediate danger but after king b3
white is definitely not worst verse
might even be better by now because of
the
passers and these pawns are yet to be in
motion so let's take a look at the big
matchup between parhamov and
fabiano
so fabiano did manage to plant the
knight on c6
but buying itself will not win the chess
game
so here goes fabiano's knight tonight d2
and i kind of anticipate the rod being
knight b1 knight a3
trying to eliminate that b5 pawn or even
knight b1 knight c3
so after the exchanges you can go rook
c3 rook a3
rook a5 not only hassling that a6 bishop
but attacking the b5 pawn so possibly
the big plan is to go here
knight b1 knight c3 and the best chance
for maksudu would be to take on d2
on the other hand that would weaken the
king here knight b1 knight c3
looks very very strong
knight c3 is coming
and after doubling there'll be
issues on the a file
and if you ask me i have no answers for
you i think black
is out of ideas you will have to take it
and after that
white gets the a file which might just
prove decisive
you can't really go for f5 breaks
because your king is just too weakened
in that case
it's knight c3 he goes knight a3 rogue
b7
knight a5 just chasing the rook away and
just
trying to get there rook c7 take and you
take on b5
and as that pawn
evaporates that should be just
a clean advantage for fabiano
so let's take a look at dominguez's game
he has that majority on
the king side however this rook
can be quite annoying so it's not quite
clear
if it's enough for a win just yet
rook f5 i assume king g6 just
sticking close to the pawn because
if you win this pawn king e6
which looks a little fishy
because the king definitely should
belong to the king side
now if you take then there's check and
rook takes c2
but the question is whether white can
somehow win the g pawn and again
get something like two extra connected
pawns
which would give ample chances for a win
king e6 but if push comes to shove
dominguez can still go back to d2 and
have a stable but a small advantage
on the other hand he has a minute versus
a minute 46
which makes this position somewhat
dangerous
he goes for rook takes c7 king g3 rook
takes c2
and it does feel that the c pawn might
be just too
fast so holding this game
might be might and could become a
priority
for dominguez
meanwhile karana won his
extra pawn but let's take a look back
at the critical the trocian vastly so
game
left it off over here five
take sticks take sticks
knight d6 rook c7 knight e4
takes takes rookie six and this looks
very ugly with this king being
overly exposed black is in big danger
and g8 check bishop f6
and that looks like decisive
because you can't take there's queen f5
and
it is a loss because a loss of
a rook and then a knight
97
but that does lose material
rookie 7 queen f5 and queen g6
is game over or rook g1 and that means
that armenia does get the lead
while jeffrey zhang made a draw
so it's one and a half half in the lead
of
armenian eagles so two games left
and that means that there
needs to be an end meanwhile
magsootlou fought back no longer is the
position
that bad and corona has very little to
no time left
on the clock
so this is the other game the other one
so one of these the american
st louis team has to win goes for a5
and again that's a minute against seven
and after rook f8 this looks
more like a draw than anything else
and that would mean that
this game has to be decisive
rook takes rook
here and the game is drawn
but still peace is on the board so you
never know
rookie two that is a free pawn
for a hike mater saying he doesn't even
take it he goes
for that one pushes the pawn
and that means that
if the two games end in a draw
that would clinch for armenia king g2
so they've been going back and forth
here
but then maxudu decided
to go for the pawnwin
and this is looking quite bad
for fabiano
rook g4 rook f2 check just going back
there and objectively
here white can't really hope
more than a draw but let's stick to the
game between
maksudu and karuana
knight e4 trying to hold it all together
g4 queen f3 is incoming
and that is being a big issue
for par i mean for fabiano
there king g1
seems to be one of the best ways of
holding but there's knight d2
king g1 indeed rapture queen e4
knight f3 is the one he goes for h4
knight f3 is also a problem after f
takes
check
and there's male f3
there
so fabiano is in big
danger meanwhile the other game
is
on seconds king f6
f takes queen f1 and knight f3 is
checkmating and
with both games lost
armenia clinches with
fabiano corona losing to maxudu
and leni dominguez losing which was
actually a surprising turn of events
as caruana did have a very strong
position in the beginning
but then it just all turned sour as
probably
time was just ticking down
and was kind of the final
reason why it kind of backfired
so that means that armenia claims the
title
with nine and a half points versus
six and a half claiming
the championships
that means st louis is second
gets the second place
with armenia winning and the
pandas finishing on third
yeah and we are going to go for a little
break now
and then we'll be back stay tuned
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the us chess championships and
the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills and increased
confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the u.s and world chess
halls of faint
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess
art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries
and a premier gift shop highlight the
culture history
and creativity behind the game come
visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus
visit stlchestcampus.org
mm-hmm
hello and welcome back this was a hard
fought match between the saint louis
archbishops
and the armenia eagles and
here we have the results for
the whole protest league finals
with armenia claiming the championship
in a hard fought battle versus the
archbishops
so that means armenia gets the gold
singles archbishops
gets the silver and in the
battle between the chinese pandas and
the
chess bras the pandas proved to be
superior
and therefore the pandas get
the bronze medal so thank you so much
for having me here again thanks for
having such a wonderful team designed by
team manager mike cummer so thank you so
much for watching
and see you take care
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube
and twitch channels we're also holding
tournaments and private lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
you